hello everyone today we're looking at
Roberta a robustly optimized bird
pre-training approached by eun-hyung Leo
and I love mainly on Facebook research
so these this paper is a pretty short
pretty simple paper and the main premise
is we've seen a number of improvements
over the initial bird paper where
different different pre-training of of
the transformer architecture or
extension extensions of the architecture
have been shown to have better
performance than the original bird model
and this paper basically says if you get
the design choices right then Burt is
able to basically be on par or exceed
all of these other methods so far so
they're they're basically exploring
design choices in the pre training and
training of of Burt alright so if you
don't know what Burt is by the way I
have made a video about Burt I've also
made a video about transformers a in
very quick terms Burt is a language
neural network architecture that takes
as input text such as this kind of thing
you see here texts such as that and it
will kind of encode it out and it can do
various things for example classify it
into certain categories or kind of
segmented extract answers from questions
and so on that the whole thing is is pre
trained with what's called a mask
language model objective which were you
don't need labels to train it so in a
masked language model objective you
basically mask out certain words during
training and then you ask Burt to
reconstruct these words from the
surrounding information and that kind of
has given some improvements in the
original bird paper but
subsequent papers have claimed that you
can improve even more by using different
retraining objectives and so on such as
Excel net but here these researchers
basically explore different things so
they use a regular bird architecture
that's what they describe here so they
use both the bird base at 12 layer as
well as the 24 layer bird that has
originally originally been described
they use masked language modeling as a
pre training objective and they explore
the necessity of this next sentence
prediction loss that has been part of
bird so along with the mask sentence
modeling bird has also had an objective
where if you input a piece of actually
you input two pieces of text two
sentences such as this these are two
sentences and bird has to decide if the
second sentence follows the first
sentence in the corpus or in 50% of the
cases the second sentence is sampled
from a different document this kind of
HA is so the original paper argued this
is necessary to incorporate long
distance relationships between text yeah
here the the NSP objective was designed
to improve performance on downstream
tasks such as natural language inference
and this paper kind of explores the
necessity of that loss in terms of
optimization there is of course kind of
a pre-training scheme and then a
training scheme using Adam here with
certain parameters and also this paper
explores the use of this of these
parameters lastly you have data and of
course these these models sometimes
they're trained on different data and
that's why they're comparing them it
makes it a bit harder to compare them
because the pre training is done on
differently sized and different races
differently structured data this this
paper also trust in
the state the influence of the training
date and especially what happens if we
keep the training data constant so all
right so they implement birthday
reemployment Burt and then they fix some
hyper parameters while they tune others
and first of all the data set so they
use different data sets the original
Burt has been trained on this book
corpus and Wikipedia English Wikipedia
data set which is 16 gigabytes of large
now this paper here collects a what's
this CC news data set which is a subset
of the common crawl news data set which
is all in so the subsidies that is the
English portion and that's 76 gigabytes
which is on par with for example what
GPT 2 used I believe so this is a very
large training set and kind of comparing
this original data to the large corpus
kind of what influence that is should
make very clear what the influence of
more training of more pre training data
is now they also have a number of other
corpora open web text as well as here I
believe there's one more stories yes so
these are also are pretty sizable but
these are like yeah these are like halfs
very specific schemas to them then the
evaluation here happens on several
different kind of downstream tasks so
the idea is you first you pre train this
Bert model on with the masked language
modeling and so on and then you have
this glue task which is actually a
collection of nine tasks and you have
some some other tasks such as squad
which is a question answering
task
and here race I don't even I don't know
what that is in particular but just
suffice to say these are kind of
downstream NLP tasks the paper isn't
about these downstream tasks but that is
just a way to measure how well your
pre-training worked if then you can
fine-tune on such a task and you get a
good performance but what the tasks are
in particular isn't too important all
right so here we get into the meat of
the paper first they they decide on what
they call static versus dynamic masking
so in the original bird paper whenever
they do masked language modeling they
take a piece of text and they basically
replicate it a bunch of times because
they want to iterate through training
data a bunch of times and then they in
each iteration they mask out different
different tokens and they compare the
they compare this to what's called
dynamic masking so this is static
masking dynamic masking sorry
dynamic masking would be where you in
each basically on the fly generate your
mask
you don't pre compute it and save it you
on-the-fly generate it this allows you
to go through kind of more or less of
the data as you want and when you
encounter the same sample twice even
though you replicate it in the original
bird model you could still encounter it
twice if you trained for longer than the
number of replications then you
basically see the exact same mask again
and the the dynamic masking actually
much more useful it's much more ad hoc
each time you see a sample you generate
the mask on the fly so they compare this
here and they see that there is a
marginal improvement that you're higher
as better marginal improvement in two
tasks and a less marginal decrease in
performance in one
tasks so they decide that this dynamic
masking is of use second thing they
investigate is the kind of input format
and this next sentence prediction so as
as I already said the original bird
training objective always gets two
sentences next to each other and has to
decide if the second one follows from
the first one actually it doesn't it
observes two concatenated document
segments which are either sampled
contiguously from the same document or
from distinct documents and this is
half-and-half
so in addition to the mask language
modeling the model is trained to predict
whether the observed documents segments
come from the same or distinct document
via an auxiliary next sentence
prediction loss and they investigate
different ways of including or excluding
this loss so first is what they they
define if here if it's plus and SP that
means that this particular thing
includes the next sentence or next
segment prediction loss so they have
segments pair plus n SP which means that
each input has a pair of segments and
these segments now the difference the
distinction between a segment and a
sentence is important where at where the
sentence is really a natural sentence a
segment can actually be multiple natural
sentences which is what the original
bird does so as long as the combined
length is less than 512 tokens there can
also be multiple sentences but there's
clearly two segments and you have to
decide if they follow after each other
or not the second thing they try is the
same thing so the next segment
prediction but now it's just two
sentences it's just natural sentences
so it must be one sentence a a a a call
a period sorry and and then the next
sentence a period and you have to
distinguish these two if they follow or
not then they investigate full sentences
which is they leave away this next
segment prediction loss and they simply
fill up the 512 tokens with text from
the corpus so each input is packed with
full sentences sampled contiguously from
one or more documents and the one or
more document means if you so if you
sample text right to your sample here
text you put all of this in the thing
and you are at the end of a document you
simply continue with the next one and go
on until you have to be 512 tokens so
you basically fill fill fill until you
have 512 tokens and that's that's this
this variant here and then in the last
variant you do the same thing that's
called dock sentences but you basically
you stop at the end so even so you put
all of this in your state and even if
you here you stop and then you have to
you know be content by simply padding
the rest of the 512 tokens or something
like this so you don't have as much data
but the all the text that you have in
one sample is actually contiguous text
from the same document so they hit these
four things against each other this is
this table here and as you can see here
the best thing is this doc sentences
thing so on these thing followed by the
full sentences and coding right so
there's some some ambiguities here but
in general you can kind of rank them as
best second best and then here third
best and four
best and they conclude that this next
segment or next sentence prediction loss
here is more hurtful than helpful in the
ways we see here and they say even
though this is most most effective they
in their case they'd rather go with this
one because it's well I guess easier to
implement you get more data through the
model in the same time and the
performance decrease isn't that much so
but it's pretty interesting to see that
this next next segment next sense
prediction isn't super super helpful in
in actuality here so removing the NSP
loss matches or slightly improves the
downstream task performance this is yeah
in contrast to what the original bird
authors found but you have to keep in
mind this is also non hasn't a bunch of
other changes in then next thing they
investigate batch size so batch size
sorry
batch size pretty seems to be pretty
interesting for these large models in
that they love large batch sizes and
they actually explore batch sizes 512
here as a smallest one and they go up to
8,000 so this they do this actually in a
data parallel way where there are many
many machines with many GPUs and they
paralyze the data and then they
accumulate the gradient of all of these
different samples and so they can go up
to a batch size about 8k and they find
generally that the 2,000 batch size here
as you can see helps to improve the so
perplexity lower is better and the other
numbers higher is better helps to to
improve the performances if you control
the control for data set size so the
number of times you go through the data
set is the same
but if you go it with a larger batch
size that seems to help up to a point
here that mm seems to be the best they
found so again a marginal improvement
you can make by training with larger
batch sizes and then this the last thing
they've looked at is actually is text
encoding so how do you encode text and
the the pit here is basically between
bite pair encoding or word piece
encoding to that to decide how large
your vocabulary is basically and as I
understand it they didn't find a much of
a difference between the different
implementations of the text encoding so
they decide they go with they decide to
go with one I don't even remember one
which one I think they go decided to go
with by pair encoding instead of word
pieces all right so they combine all of
this into Roberta which is the robust
the optimized Burt approach and they say
Roberta is trained with dynamic masking
so what they showed first full sentence
without the next segment prediction loss
large mini-batches a larger byte level
byte parent coding as well as of course
their collection of training data and
then here they also investigate how long
to pre train
so if you look at the original burt
models or the excel net models and then
compare it to Roberta's Roberta this is
the original data and they already beat
Burt yet they do not they do not yet
beat Excel net with that so if they add
data they get even better actually on
par mostly with the with Excel that if
they pre train longer
they get even better and if they were to
say pre-trained even longer right so
that here's the the number of steps if
you're a number of steps then match the
number of steps that the Excel net does
with the same additional data then or
with their additional data then you
outperform Excel net as well so this
this kind of just an an overview of this
and they evaluate on other downstream
tasks and they basically show that in
most of them they can reach
state-of-the-art performance or exceed
it with their approach and in conclusion
they basically say well this only shows
that kind of the the gains that these
other models make and the reasons why
they make gains may be questionable if
you simply pre-trained burped in a
better way you can reach the same
performances so I think the end is not
reached yet most of all they publish
their code their data I believe I have
not looked into this but definitely
check out their repository where this is
implemented it seems pretty easy seems
pretty straightforward and that was it
for me bye-bye